who would wear this my uncle oh this
sounds like my dad that smells like my
dad likes open sea water sorta tropical
but uh like musky like an older person
this reminds me a guy wearing a
button-up blue shirt where it's like not
offensive but there's nothing really
individual about it the kind of men that
wear this they're the kind of men that
things that women that they meet at the
bar are gonna have sex
yeah I'm not by data but I'd be their
friend smells like an old man like spicy
man oh that smells like my dad too
this is a man who will have sex with you
and you will like it a picture like
someone from like The Godfather this is
a little too acidic I'm looking for
something a little more grounded in a
man and then blown douchebag bro tool my
ex-boyfriend
this is like the smell that lingers
after that weird guide the bar that's
talking to you finally leaves I'm just
trying to dance at the club and this guy
was wearing this it's trying to like the
oh my but this guy probably doesn't know
anything interesting because he's been
working really hard on getting the
perfect five o'clock shadow a buff man
with a soft side to him so like a fuzzy
bear this is a boy this is not a man the
boy wears this same guys wear hat I
totally did this guy I might like have
sex with this guy okay this is a
douchebag to turned to a dad he smells
like he would be handsome like a
handsome prince
who owns his own house and Lamborghini
musky but not in like an unpleasant way
the guy that wears this perfume is
hoping to be rugged and elegant at the
same time not realizing that that
actually doesn't is
Javad how do I get this out of the
bottle and onto my skin is sweet as hell
it's like a tannery I don't want my guy
to smell like what my hair was not like
we confuse me sexually this is something
that my future lover will wear oh I'd
really marry this guy I think the
sensitive brows wearing this this is the
guy that'll like take you out for dinner
and talk about his family and his
feelings but really he's only thinking
about what kind of panties you have on
everyone should be wearing this you wear
this and you just smell like success I'm
not weird